we're gonna take just one more call this
is the last caller this is someone who's
been waiting on hold for 16 minutes at
this point I want to get to them who am
I talking to hi David my name is Adam
I'm in DC great to hear from you what's
on your mind um yeah I've been um kind
of following independent news not
mainstream media news and read it seems
like we're heading back to the thirties
with the rise of ultra conservative
parties in other countries like I mean
starting with breakfast in the UK and
then the Golden Dawn party in Greece
yemm's hungary and poland and marina
Paul and France and I don't know I mean
what are your thoughts on that we are
and we've covered the rise of right-wing
nationalist parties all over Europe and
this includes even in in other countries
than the ones you mentioned there are
people who are indeed seeing Trump's
sort of authoritarian populist rhetoric
as matching up with that uh yes I mean I
can't disagree with you the only
question I have is how far is this going
to go and is it going to evolve into
something else or bigger or more than
what we're already sort of seeing
ideologically we see that the the white
nationalist and the anti-semites are
really emboldened by the Trump win and
you're absolutely right you're
recognizing the trend and and I
completely agree with you i mean do you
are or do you have a sense of where it's
going to go I think I'm being kind of
pessimistic I mean I think we're kinda
headed for world war three it this might
mean maybe I'm being paranoid but I hope
you are I mean I hope not world war
three but I don't they are not you get
out yeah I think many in our audience
have expressed that this is the type of
direction that could lead not
necessarily to the sort of armed
traditional war type conflict but more
into new cold war-style issues with
individual countries i think there's
they're sort of something interesting
there and when you hear about trade wars
like Trump is suggesting that's the type
of thing where
yeah some people say trade war could
lead to real war but trade war is really
most analogous to something that is more
cold war like and I don't know I mean
you know the guy hasn't even been
inaugurated yet I guess we'll have
plenty of time to sort it out and the
other thing I just find really
disturbing about is that whole
nationalistic thing that just seems to
be becoming more widespread yeah yeah I
mean we've covered that extensively in
that that's probably a whole other
conversation but I share a lot of your
concerns and in DC great to hear from
you really really appreciate it that is
going to do it for calls for us for
today and we will take more calls next
week we'll be taking calls uh earlier in
the week next week because we do have a
different schedule there will be no
friday show with the Thanksgiving break
thanks to everybody who called and sorry
to everybody we were not able to get to